Ciao ragazzi bentornati a una nuova
puntata di Cucina Buttata, fra una
settimana è Pasqua ed è per questo che
ho deciso di fare un uovo di Pasqua
della Kinder a casa, da solo. Da solo, siamo 2000 (Rico). Si. Ci stanno 1, 2, 3, 4, 5, 6, 7, sette persone più una che
sta suonando il pianoforte nell'altra stanza.
Comunque per fare l'uovo di Pasqua della
Kinder avremo bisogno di...cioccolato Milka.
Non lo abbiamo mangiato e cioccolato
bianco. Non lo abbiamo mangiato. Ci sono
un sacco di tutorial che parlano dei
palloncini, cioè fanno vedere come
utilizzare...no questi sono quelli piccoli
piccoli, grazie mille assistente. Chef Palla
mi ha dato una mano. "Chef Palla" ahhha (Chef Rico)... Un sacco di tutorial per fare
facilmente le uova a casa usano i palloncini
Partiamo dal presupposto che per quanto
tu li possa lavare, gonfiare e sgonfiare
secondo me, boh, secondo me son mezzi
nocivi, abbiamo abbandonato il
divertimento del "Facciamo i palloncini
tutti insieme", per evitare di morire subito
dopo e utilizzeremo invece una formina
per uova. E' molto semplice da trovare
in descrizione vi ho messo un pochino di link
più economici o meno. La prima cosa che
dovremo fare quindi è temperare il
cioccolato e cospargere la parte esterna
diciamo dei gusci con il cioccolato al latte
Aspetteremo che si riscaldi...che si riscaldi? Che si raffreddi (Rico)
Sono molto stanco. Aspettiamo che si raffreddi e poi tempreremo il cioccolato bianco e faremo
un altro strato che lo andrà a coprire
totalmente per fare quell'effettino
...aspettando sempre che si riscaldi anche
quello. Partiamo subito! Temperare il
cioccolato non è una cosa facilissima ma
ci sono un bel po' di tutorial
dov'è il mio telefono? Io senza quello
non riesco a cucinare. Ah è vero il
grembiule pure. Pallotta il Grembiule sotto al sedere! (Rico). Chef!
Dov'è sta il ttelefono? Dov è seate el talefeno?
Pallotta! (*voci sovrapposte*). Ora tu hai paura dei palloncini
ce ne abbiamo tanti e non ne stiamo facendo
scoppiare nemmeno uno. Questo qui è il
Robertometro, Se Roberta sta per fare
qualcosa io faccio questo
No ti prego! (Roberta). Oggi devo trovare i
vostri punti deboli. Il mio è avere casa pulita (Purci)
Il cioccolato al latte deve raggiungere
i 45/50 gradi
e poi lo dobbiamo far scendere a 27.
Utilizzeremo un termometro da cucina
anche qua sotto vi ho messo nell'infobox
la possibilità di acquistarlo su Amazon
Dobbiamo sciogliere a bagnomaria.
Ma perché è così tante ciotole? Cioè
dovete sciogliere un sacco di cose a bagnomaria?...Senti Roby
L'acqua non deve toccare il pentolino? Fatelo sciogliere a bagnomaria
No l'acqua non deve toccare la brocca (Chef Mario)
Se questo qui è il procedimento sbagliato,
quello che ho detto Gianmarco, la colpa è
sua. Come fai a fare l'acqua se non ha un recipiente?
Come fai a fare l'albero senza il seme?
Tu non hai una ricetta alla quale ti stai...noo. Oggi
sto andando un pochino più, si si sta
arrivando la Pasqua e quindi mi sento
più "Uuu"...E' preferibile che l'acqua del
pentolino non sfiori il fondo della
bastardella in cui avrete messo il
cioccolato Jon Snow. Non lo sfiora,
perfetto
Quanto cioccolato servirà per...poco! (Rico). Pochissimo
La cosa difficile è raffreddarlo,
devi stare lì con la spatola, le cose. Noi non
abbiamo niente tutto questo, quindi
proveremo a raffreddarlo con un metodo alternativo
Maitre chocolatier...Senti io metto pure questo almeno sto tranquillo e sereno
Ma te lo sei mangiato? Ma cosa? Te lo sei mangiato! Non so di che cosa stai parlando
Ma con cosa lo giro?
Mentre faccio uno e lo raffreddo girando...un phon!
Un phon con l'aria fredda (Chef Devi). Scusa ma riempi una bacinella d'acqua
e li giri dentro una bacinella con l'acqua fredda dentro, ci metti il ghiaccio dentro (Purci)
Quindi facciamo un bagno maria al
contrario, bagno Giuseppe
Cioè io sto mischiando con la testa dell'Uomo Focaccina...Tiè!
Proviamolo. Cioè stiamo a 33 gradi? (Rico)
Fermo nonono sto sbagliando tutto. Secondo
stiamo salendo troppo. Vedi? 40, 42, 43, ci
stiamo. Fortunato (Rico)
Io direi professionista. Più che altro tu hai preso l'unica spatola coi buchi (Rico). La domanda è
qual è invece una spatola senza buchi?
Cioccolato bianco. Deve scendere fino a
27 il cioccolato al latte e quello
bianco deve salire a 45 e poi scendere
tra i 26 e i 25...Ragazzi ma questo solo che c'ha?
Che si sposta alla velocità del sole
E' sempre a 45/46. Secondo me ci saranno le
persone, i cioccolatieri che mi diranno
Che c***o fai?! Però ragazzi "A mali estremi estremi
rimedi", perdonatemi. Non abbiamo niente, in
primis la volontà. Poi non so voi
ragazzi, per quanto mi riguarda Pasqua
uguale uovo Kinder. Tutti gli altri
buoni ma comunque un gradino sotto.
Fatemi sapere qual è il vostro preferito
Ma no ma c'ho ancora tutto il cioccolato
qui da mettere...Mi sento di aver fatto
una sciocchezza qui (*palloncino che esplode). Non l'ho fatto apposta Ro
Dovevamo arrivare a 45 ma mi sono distratto. Sta salendo
vertiginosamente. Questo qui sta diventando più una
pastella, questo qui invece ancora super
liquido
Ma qual'è la sorpresa? (Luigi). Amore la sorpresa è piena del
mio amore per te. Hai paura che non sia
abbastanza grande l'uovo? Questo vedi come è più...
Fa vedere quello (Rico). Quello è quasi tipo quello
delle pubblicità (Mario). 27 ragazzi
U! Esatto! Movimenti rotatori. Guarda che carini, li vedi? (Mario)
Madonna ragazzi miei! (Rico)
Come si toglie lo stampino?
Lo devi fa solidificà (Rico) e poi tipo come levi il ghiaccio dai ghiaccetti spero (Mario)
Prendiamo a questo punto della carta
forno e lasciamo riposare lo stampo a
testa in giù per una decina di minuti
Cambia Giuseppe (Rico). Cambio Giuseppe vai.
Io faccio questa cosa nella speanza che si riempia
più velocemente. Copro la distanza. Eh ma poi la riallunghi (Rico)
Eh lo so, non è servito a niente. Però all'ultimo...se lo fai all'ultimo...esatto (Rico)
Però posso dire, per Pasqua molto meglio cercare di fare un uovo al cioccolato che farsi crocifiggere
Non si fa crocifiggere per Paqua
Ah no risur...risurresc...E' un po' una crocifissione questo. Io faccio una cosa
che non si dovrebbe fare ma non mi interessa. Secondo me hai fatto la scelta saggia (Rico). Grazie
Magari non ti si stacca proprio per questo motivo (Mario). 28! Scendiamo
di un grado, e ogni volta si gioisce, un po'
come con la febbre
A 28 gradi sei morto (Rico)
2 gradi cosa, sono due gradi? Quelli che mi mancano alla vista (Rico). E' vero. Possono fare
seri problemi quindi...Sto bagno Giuseppe è inutile!
Io intanto vorrei staccarle. Non è
così facile non pensarlo. Eh lo so ma
anche staccarle, intere. Cioè io so che tu
hai davanti a te un professionista e quindi pensi che io possa fare di tutto
non riesco a fare tutto Gianmarco. Sale a 27 o rimane a 26? E' temperato!
E secondo me quella botta di frigo gli ha fatto un bene! (Rico)
Sì sono molto opacizzati effettivamente. Eh opaco (Rico)
Che bello! (Chef Devi). E' bellissimo ragazzi! (Chef Rico)
Ho versato questo
cioccolato all'interno di un cioccolato
che stava in frigo. C'è una lotta, spero
che vinca il latte, anche se io
preferisco il bianco. Io non capisco come
fanno alcune persone a preferire il fondente boh!
Non sono persone (Chef Mario)
Ok stiamo mettendo uno strato enorme
Nonono hai fatto una c*****a! (Rico). Mayday! Raffredare!
A questo punto facciamo partire il timer
per mezz'ora...non ho più fede. E' passata
mezz'ora, è arrivato il momento quindi di
tirare fuori le formine dal frigo
Wow! Wow! (Mario e Rico)
Vabbè non è perfetto questo qui in particolare.
Non so se si nota. Si dovrebbero levare
abbastanza facilmente (Mario). Ah a prendere
proprio fisicamente...fare leva (Chef Devi)
Ma come fai scusa, ma che mani c'ha questa? (Rico). Piazziamo una canzone?
*strana imitazione di una canzone cristiana*
Madonna so tutte un blocco Gu. Questa mi
sembra la roba migliore per rovinare...romperlo.Però lei dice di farla questa cosa (Mario). Eh ma come fa?
Liberare le cavità (Mario). Il perimetro. Ma lei chi che
la ringraziamo intanto a questa. Nonono, Gu
lo rovini (Rico). Oh lo dice lei (Mario), ma sta a di na s*******a, guarda che sta a creà! (Rico)
"Le uova si staccano bene". Le uova si staccano bene
"Adesso arriviamo al punto critico". Il punto critico? Più critico di questo?
Ma rimarrà per sempre così. Senti è fallito!
Portatemi un phon caldo...fidati!
Un phon! Che cosa possiamo fare?
Cosa possiamo fare? Oddio ragazzi sono
Daenerys! Oh ma c'è qualcuno in bagno? Riscaldalo col phon (Purci)
Eh che faccio sfondo la porta mentre quella poveraccia...no però puoi sfondare la cunina (Purci)
Ohh ha fatto la cacca. Aprite la finestra (Rico)
No mo ti faccio vedere io
Dovevamo prenderli in silicone. Nono sta a fa un macello! Eh ma non si
stacca. E' andato questo ormai. il sapore
sembra buono. Te lo dico subito
Regà pazzesco! No lo rovini Gu! Troviamo una soluzione. (Rico). Ma che soluzione (Mario). Ma che
soluzione! Noo pure col cucchiaio. Guarda...col cucchiaio
E questo è l'effetto finale dell'uovo che abbiamo fatto
ragazzi che dire che dire
Che dire ragazzi, secondo me c'è stato un piccolo errore
col cioccolato al latte, perché il bianco
è perfettamente duro, quello al latte ha
un non so che di spugnoso. Lo vogliamo
assaggiare ragazzi? E' più pastoso...più pastoso...e quindi più appiccicoso (Mario)
Per favore foodblogger unisciti a me
Io sto per avere le visioni per quanto zucchero
Ma questo chi è? Cosa vuole? (Rico)
E' bono. Oh è buono. Certo che potevi avere la pazienza di
far vedere l'uovo intero. Eh lo so. L'hai voluto rompere subito. Volevo vedere che
sorpresa c'era dentro. Mi ero
dimenticato che l'avevo chiuso vuoto
Voto pollice in su. Anche perché dopo sette ore io mi suicido se dici che fa schifo
Questo è il nostro Uovo di Pasqua. Dei consigli
per evitare che risulti questo. State attenti
ai procedimenti che fate. Molto
probabimente ho sbagliato qualcosa
perché uno è venuto bello duro, l'altro
abbastanza molliccio. Un altro consiglio
che vi do e che vi metto anche qui
nell'info box, prendete le formine per
fare l'uovo in silicone. Il fatto che
siano morbide aiuta in un certo senso
a tirar fuori l'uovo. Terza cosa compratelo già fatto
Che altro dire...io intanto vi auguro...no non ve lo posso augurare con anticipo. Vi augurio
Inoltre vi auguriò di
iscrivervi a questo canale, di attivare
la campagna qua sotto per non
perdere le prossime puntate che ci
saranno di Cucina Buttata e che dire...ci
vediamo la prossima domenica
Ciao